oh hey : bros today it's a special day
because you will see my face the entire
video I change to a [ __ ] webcam I
have the most expensive camera the most
top-notch equipment but it can't [ __ ]
record a gameplay video [ __ ] me right i
Rebecca meet some Bradbury thank y'all
for coming a fashion tip Jack you roll
your jeans up a little high find a way
to the garage got it
I need I know what needs to be done fire
away and that's how you open the door
ladies and bros thank you everyone
top of the morning to you laddies that's
the discreet way I'm doing it rip city
see it happen ah ha ha shelves I forgot
it doesn't last long
don't tell anyone and we're back Oh God
they really wanted you to die they're
[ __ ] [ __ ]
no they give you no time for that
explosion ok brew it in guys we're in
where are we going Bros I keep looking
at the wrong camera op as soon as I saw
the old billboard on top the area we
refer to as ground fire
you're dead and you're dead you're dead
you're dead man you're all dead you're
also dead let me reload thank you
I am the top of the morning to you
laddies Chuck septic oiler Oh God who
did that oh this could be dangerous
let's wait for him come here brother
come here brother come here brother come
here come on come on aah Oh
holy [ __ ] that was [ __ ] awesome look
at this idiot look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
surprise [ __ ]
hahahaha that's cool you're dead that's
a good good mood let me get closer what
the [ __ ] just happened oh my god what if
I could turn back time
that's gonna that's gonna sting tomorrow
don't worry about it okay let's see
let's climb this and let's climb this
and then I'm gonna go here and [ __ ] all
of y'all ha ha oh my god there's another
one with powers just like s that look
like sensitive equipment that they have
on their back I wonder what happens if I
shoot it
stutters you the brush Whitaker prepared
for it oh [ __ ] you never tried to stop
it so they prepared for people like me
that's pretty cool
oh [ __ ] they know how to do [ __ ] too
well that's too bad
Oh what what are you doing me hahahaha
oh yeah we first time I forgot that's
cool alright where's the other one
hey you're in my domain a [ __ ]
literally look at him oh there's more oh
[ __ ] how many other surprise
[ __ ] it's pretty cool action I
gotta say like honestly guys you're
pretty easy to kill and that's my stand
yeah look at this so cool you get that
part of his life for me haha where are
you going Betty waiting there
where you going Betty and even though it
was just get me lewd to the back
hahahahahaha same place later yeah hey
see you later buddy to the sky oh my God
look at the sky hey where'd he go that's
[ __ ]
I'm trying to make him fly fly [ __ ] fly
probably here bronzer oh here it is baby
the bat bat better fatfat up a bit about
that bat up at bat and we're back
what what what is this I'm looking at
myself awkward so if I look back now I
should see oh my god what the [ __ ] what
is this um that already happened awkward
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the that's
cool this game is getting cooler and
cooler guys I gotta say I don't know
what you think but it started off not
that strong but it's pretty [ __ ] cool
I'm not gonna lie I specifically
requested copper clad niobium wolf
oh this is his vault
okay-y what is the words to describe
what was gone but we see him build it
that's cogs all around this entire
secret life he never talked about
everything he tried to protect me from
it surrounding me a puzzle trapped in
broken time
we all thought he wasted his research
grant his career he built all this by
himself for some failed experiment he's
serious what he led us to believe what
he built there
he never failed it works
wait so he build it
that's cool
holy [ __ ] me my graphics tended another
year here please please don't do those
to this
what are you playing pong there buddy he
sleeps on a mattress what a little nerd
countermeasure I hope that God s workers
will it's gone
this is really dope what are the only
other one oh he try to convince her oh I
knew something went horribly wrong there
but it was scrambled it's impossible to
crack that's [ __ ] cool man
um I don't know what's going on though
where am I supposed to go here Sheldon
the cafeteria how much time is passing
right now this reminds me of
interstellar doesn't it yeah let's look
at the picture huh oh [ __ ] hell it
scares me every time okay what do we got
here this is so cool
every that's a question I had was
compounded by what I'd seen at that
workshop the events at university would
part of something much bigger something
that had started 17 years ago
goodbye Grand Sarah okay drydock get to
the drydock
almost there Jesus Christ how far is it
gotta get to Paul I love his picture hi
what's crack-a-lackin' yow what's
cracking there was something wrong haha
something wrong with me I'm a [ __ ]
murderer Jesus much longer than me what
was the cause was I sick as well or was
it his time travel I didn't know it
didn't make anything you'd done any less
hateful okay we're going into this
building do we have any people in here
no we're fine
yeah gee oh oh yeah Jack you have to
understand that well what the hell
happened to you there's no you spiders
you kill them I'll explain when the time
is right
don't meet me tonight at the modern
collar gala time's ending and you're
having a [ __ ] party because when time
ends
Michael do this now I'm not meat analyst
you are I've already seen it happened
seeing what what's this all for goodbye
jack what an [ __ ] I would not go if
he told me that he told me that I'd be
like you know what a [ __ ] off mate I'm
not going to your party all right and
this is free beer then maybe I'll
consider it all right
oh come on [ __ ] sir
he's got the girl from the trailer shoot
ah what
oh [ __ ]
well good thing time stop now that's a
good time for time to stop thanks time I
appreciate your camp time now how should
we do this something about maybe turning
back time post if I could turn back time
there you go you're fine good go fess up
bad this thing is gonna the ship is
gonna sail what the [ __ ] was that you
barely touched me ah did you see that
baby that was stupid come on come on
come on come on
what the [ __ ] this part is [ __ ]
stupid
why didn't he I here we go
oh my [ __ ] lord I did it Wow Wow that
was worth it he's shifting back and
forth that one the time I didn't think
you get much worse but we both did I
feel like I'm in a dubstep music video
what the [ __ ] is this
squealed little Jack [ __ ] you
what the hell is going on here this is
crazy
okay well this arrow points this way so
gonna assume I'm going here it's cool
though it's really [ __ ] cool
what what oh god I did something I
didn't a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh well then what happened jack
achoo good point good point you make a
solid case there Jack flat foeman
platforming I love to platformer baby
bear platform for me any day yeah nice
one Jack that was my that's that's it
you got it
what okay that makes sense
I'm fine I'm actually fine how about
that almost that out okay we're gonna go
with that here now and I guess here okay
yeah you know what [ __ ] it I have no
idea what's going on you go
yeah but Jack is telling me to keep
going so whoop
um I'm gonna run never mind I'll stay
here oh this is cool
I mean the time thing in combat is
pretty dumb
oh man the recoil on this [ __ ] thing
Jesus
yeah I'm kicking ass wow that was a
boxer right in my [ __ ] face and
that's how I stand one more
Arius we're gonna finish you off with
style ah
and that's how much done baby [ __ ] yeah
now let's talk to Beth method bitterly
that was cool that was awesome who's
frozen somewhere up there outside of the
bride car was [ __ ] dope all right
where's Beth I swear to god Beth where
the oh hello Beth and my xbox crashed
because Edgar is sitting on it God that
Karen that son of a [ __ ]
hopefully I won't have to replay
everything at least are you [ __ ]
kidding me
god damn it ed God okay I'm back Edgar
is here now you [ __ ] [ __ ] and yeah
let's find Beth that oh my god that
actually worked
what the [ __ ] yeah nailed it
high five bro haha there we go Babette I
bet so what did you do today huh great
look at his ass ship has sailed
falling captain ha ha ha I don't trust
you then shoot me Oh
she's got she's feisty oh that's for not
listening to me back there
Wow you want to stop time for breaking
down we need my help and thanks by the
way for the plus one in the backseat
started feel like god damn babysitter
hey pizza man ha ha ha ha hell yeah my
ride my music
deal with that stell would tell me that
brass I love this song
ma'am meme pizza guy I never thought
what are you calling pizza guy he's
texting guy copyrighted music thank you
thank you for it
what led you to the Swimming Hall I will
said there was something important it's
briefcase oh we're back all I found was
a key with Bradbury Swimming Hall
Cheetham Bradbury only we had I guess
this is it
what was her brother doing in this
[ __ ] hey taxi guy comes come your
[ __ ] found
I think it's time you tell me what you
know
I know your brother built the one thing
that can stop the fracture I know we're
meant to find it and I know mater
doesn't want us to and yet you're
wearing their uniform like the way their
pants fit I agree Oh taxi guy create a
cover to gather information you've known
about this for a few hours I've been
preparing for it for most of my life
convince me you weren't aware that
William owned the place
there's a lot I didn't know about will
oh [ __ ] your bags countermeasure and
fast things will get worse as the
fracture progresses I'm looking at you
pizza guy hey hey you don't hit on my
girl text a guy it's right I'm looking
at you you [ __ ]
get ya think anyone can skip like that
I'll look in the door maybe it unlocks
this key doesn't fit
welcome to reality Hey look at this taxi
taxi guy here you go you're right in
this looks a lot like your taxi can't be
I parked it way back at the holy [ __ ]
that's my goddamn license plate how the
hell did it get here I don't know bro
I don't know I have a feeling somebody
beat us here
this is all connected some kind of
message think Nick think 0 1 1 2 2 0 1 1
2 2 numbers teleport what is going on
here what am I looking at I can't get
out listen just let Jack do the work
alright hold off on posting anything
true yeah hold on for your facebook
posts okay there's a time Ripple here
please move the chair down there ya go
chair is down baby
never mind I'll wait the container of
course of course how could a bin so
bland alright now what are we gonna use
it again
yeah we are that's [ __ ] cool I like
that I like that a lot
alright now what you can't possibly
expect me to go here are you cereal damn
all of a sudden I can do all these moves
made all right we're in [ __ ] yeah
think I found a way in cool that's
awesome gotta say the time thing is
getting cool and cooler I gotta say it's
impressed me I'm like whoa that's big
[ __ ] cool it's cool I like it
hi guys taxi what I looked up the zip
code 0 1 1 2 2 it's located at south of
here oh my god can this guy ever shut
the [ __ ] up
hey committed to place mattresses ok use
the building to hide away his personal
items
ok may 17 2011 is William Joyce I'm
about to haul a lot more this place is
just some old boxes and we're open
actually need one more door what how big
is this place how this is a swimming
hole
look at him beautiful man slender legs
always go for a swimmer bird working on
it
what uh Ethan Bradberry welcome to my
Ethan Bradberry crib Ethan Bradberry and
Ethan breviary alright let's take a look
around down here
why shut the [ __ ] up taxi dude whoa
that's creepy don't do that ever again
Jesus gents let's go to the gents of
course she wants to go the gents this is
not-- it's directed at me
Oh played a video bad Wilder I'm
addressing this video to you you told me
to stay away from it wanna shop but I
couldn't just leave it there I went back
to get it and the entire place is a
disaster zone the countermeasure Dornan
taking it tired ah safe indeed I just
need to know you have it because if it
falls into the wrong hands
power is a miserable future our entire
lives depend on it
this can't all be for nothing you know
what if I me please hurry
2010 holy [ __ ] what was that he recorded
that for me in 2010 what the [ __ ]
he said the countermeasure is gone it's
not good we need to figure this out
let's keep looking
ok Beth oh hey this is it nope never
mind then sorry
[ __ ] hell where does this [ __ ] key
go help me push this out of the way ok
nailed it Jack your brother addressed
that video to me yeah I've never met him
before in my life
well it sounded like you thought you had
his countermeasure I wish but he said it
was stolen on July 4th 2010 somebody
took it yeah and whoa but I'm hoping
this place will help us figure out who
it's a swim hall bath and yacht and
bring a swimsuit I'll give you the honor
of pressing the button oh I will
oh damn it
harridan yeah I think so the Cantor myth
I'm gonna guess a good time machine this
changes everything we're gonna guess the
taxi guy is the bad guy this thing
working then we don't need that
countermeasure we can change everything
what if we stop the fracture from ever
happening in the first place we can go
back to yesterday undo everything in the
past before it happens nobody dies Paul
doesn't go through the machine monarch
never exists I mean the fracture never
hurts Jack wait hey look a beach pot
it's not how I can go into the machine
like Paulette at the University I helped
them set it up then we activate the core
put the corner in place and set the date
I can do it Beth I'm not you're sure we
can do this without the can of measure
but you're right we'll need the machine
right let's start with the core like I
built a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] Bob the
Builder says the time machine core needs
to be reset great what the hell's it
look like your mom a round thing in the
middle think I can't activate the core
till it's reset okay fine we'll reset
the core god jeez calm down everyone
we have to go down there hey it looks
like I can reset the core from here
there no clue but I did help Paul set up
the machine at the University
she then caused the fracture look will
knew the calculations were wrong hoping
that means he knew what he was doing
here
this is what will please - we have to
test it no will wanted us to get the
countermeasure you dumb [ __ ] alright
fine
alright taxi guy do something decent
okay we'll see
still resetting
why do I have to do miss reset we need
to activate it from the control booth
I think the control doohickeys right
here
Thanks tech taxi guy you're the my
favorite taxi guy here goes nothing it
yeah
damn it how did he make it soaps yeah
yeah just stopped in time don't worry
about it now we put the age on worked
1984 it actually worked
ok we activate the corridor next
I can't insert the date look at that
thing go I don't know man
there's a light blinking here might be
what you're looking well thanks Beth
genius battler its key activated wills
key of course yeah
yeah oh nice
Time Machine and he lifts a new trunk of
his goddamn
that's my brother in a nutshell uh-huh
oh we're gonna go back in town baby
that's fine let's just hope it still
works that's fine
set the date okay we set the date over
here I think yep almost there buddy
1984 what yeah that'll do it I'm gonna
try it again yeah like hell you are
you saw what happened something's wrong
with me we don't know that you're not
trained for this anything you do is
gonna make it worse you know I'm right
stop try you lost people you're angry I
get it but this is bigger than us oh my
god don't be all social justice on me
Jesus Christ yeah we can we didn't even
try come on I know somebody who can tax
a guy ha ha ha Sophia the mono scientist
I saw her video near Ground Zero
Serene's had a Cronin research
she'll be at the monarch gala tonight
but Security's airtight she'll be nearly
impossible to get to unless I have an
invite
Paul told me he expected me to meet him
at that party something tells me that
was not a friendly invitation
Jack no oh my god she's so annoying let
me have fun what just happened
well [ __ ] what the [ __ ] just happened
and of back to end of act 2 bit ah on
yeah this game is getting real
interested I like yeah some good [ __ ] my
man ok breasts well if you enjoyed this
episode please leave a like and let me
know if you want more of these as always
I really appreciate it oh but more than
anything
stay awesome bros excuse me [ __ ]